this is the shoe Nike claims can make
any runner 4% faster
it's called the vapor fly 4% we've shown
these to some of our external partners
and they've helped measure them in
independently verify them and I think
even from a science perspective they
their best scientifical term was they're
just magic to prove just how magic Nike
is attempting to break the last great
barrier in running a marathon completed
in under two hours there's a little bit
like the sub 10 seconds Thundra meters
it's a little bit like the four-minute
mile it's one of those big barriers for
kind of human potential in the past
century elite marathoners have shaved
close to an hour off the world's best
time the current record stands at two
hours two minutes and 57 seconds those
last three minutes might not seem like
much but they're the difference between
what is and isn't humanly possible this
projects about proving that emond theme
has no limitation above Orlando to Mecca
Strip
that's Elliot Kip Shogun he's one of the
best long-distance runners in the world
Nike signed on him and two other
athletes Zenit Adisa and Lolita this ISA
to try and break two hours I think the
first reaction from most of the runners
who've seen them just just visually is
they don't look like a traditional shoe
there's a little bit thicker than
they're used to certainly when they hold
them they're a little bit stiffer than
they used to and maybe in prototype days
or not as pretty as they're used to Nike
worked on that and these are the
custom-designed vapor fly elites you
won't find these in stores they were
specifically tailored for the three
runners to wear on race day inside the
shoe there are two key innovations the
sole is made from a phone that's very
light but still thick enough to support
the foot you want the athlete to be able
to take the dampening there the
suspension from their body and sort of
dissipate that through the foam
then you also want that propulsion back
out so we have this amazing foam that
does both of those like no other phone
that we've ever used in the in the past
second the soul is embedded with a
carbon fiber plate that helps with
propulsion to think of a spike plate
something that really helps propel you
through the next ride is pretty stiff
it's also very very thin and very very
light but you can tune that specifically
to your athlete needs and your running
gait but can an athlete really run 4%
faster just by putting on a pair of
shoes if everything is done properly
then I think that this is a possibility
that's been Oh neat he's an independent
expert in biomechanics he's conducted
studies on the benefit of using plates
and running shoes we have a lever here
that is about from the ankle joint to
that point here now if we have a plate
and made that plate a little bit stiff
and it'll be longer then we can increase
that lever and you can imagine that when
the lever is bigger that you have an
advantage in performance well neig
hasn't seen the shoes he says if they
are to have a major impact Nike will
have to tune the angle of the plates to
the gait of each athlete the question is
whether they do the right thing and
that's not easy that's very complicated
the tuning of a shoe for an athlete is
not an easy thing the shoes aren't the
end of Nikes plan to control as many
variables as possible
the athletes aren't running in a big
city marathon instead
Kenickie is putting on its own event at
a racetrack in Monza Italy so I'm super
confident in the product but I also know
that that's got to translate to the
human beings that are actually put
themselves on the line and in that day
but we're doing everything we can to put
them on the start line to be able to
achieve their goal there's just a few
weeks left to get everything right